men are more concerned about a woman's
past and women are more concerned about
a man's future I find that to be a
hundred percent true and women don't
like to hear that especially if they
have a past yeah it really Ruffles
feathers when you try to explain to
society that men and women are different
men are success objects right so that's
why women look at a man's future but
women are Beauty objects to men and it's
always been that way so when I tell them
it's like there's going to be
consequences to your promiscuity they
have a very very hard time understanding
that and they get upset with it and it's
usually the ones that have a promiscuous
past they get very upset with it these
women in my opinion are disgusting if
you're planning on having children why
would you want to share the womb that's
been you know used by other guys that's
why throughout history virginity was so
valued to to men and society and why
they tried to protect it it's just in
recent times that they've lied to women
and they've said go out and have fun
guys do it so you should do it too it
really started with hormonal birth
control then you could go and have sex
without consequences before there was
consequences if you had sex you could
legitimately get pregnant